hi YouTube it's ed miliband sector of
State for Energy and Climate Change in
the United Kingdom I don't think that
the environment should or will lose out
to the economy in the coming yeah but
only if we take the right decisions
obviously what's happening the economy
is at the top of people's minds of the
moment and we have to show people that
tackling climate change as the world has
pledged to do this year culminating in
Copenhagen in December 2009 and fixing
our economy creating the jobs of the
future are not inconsistently they are
consistent and that's why it's so
important that President Obama has
talked about the green stimulus as part
of his overall economic stimulus package
and i think is why important white
across countries we need to be talking
about that sort of action but i never
thing i would say is that I recognize
that government alone can't ensure that
we meet our obligations to climate in
2009 it needs people as well that's why
we need an international movement which
goes across countries are telling
politicians like me that we need to
reach a global deal in Copenhagen in
2009 it's why we need to involve
business I've been talking to business
here at Davos about that and how we
involve them in that protest is why we
need faith groups is why we need people
across society of all persuasions to be
saying look the climate is too urgent a
problem and we know that the longer we
wait the higher costs the climate's to
urgent a problem to leave and that way
we can ensure that the environment
cousin lose out to the economy in 2009